if you've been following along with this
series you've got a pretty good
understanding of the different
techniques that cloud eop uses to find
hide and protect sensitive data today
we'll find out how easy it is to build
and reuse your commonly used dlp
configurations
stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
kitty catwalks has already been using
dlp to inspect and de-identify
different data sources like archive chat
log files
issues from their ticketing system
databases and data that they collect
from customers for billing
chances are if you're anything like
kitty cat walks the data you want to
protect
may be from different sources and you
may want to inspect and de-identify that
data consistently using the same
configuration
each time this is where dlp templates
come in
templates allow you to save dop
configuration details
and reuse them against any data that you
might have essentially
decoupling configuration information
from the implementation of your request
there are two types of templates an
inspection template is going to save
any configuration having to do the
process of inspecting your data
like what info types you want to
discover a likelihood threshold
maximum number of findings to return and
exclusion rules
you can even use an inspection template
to define your own custom info type
let's see what it looks like to create a
template with some node.js code
here's an example of a request that will
send the create inspect template
function
to create an inspection template that's
configured to find phone numbers
and email addresses with a minimum
likelihood of
possible once it's been created
here's what that template looks like in
our cloud console
there's the info types we specified and
the likelihood too
let's edit our inspection template to
also include person name
we go here where it says manage info
types and enter
person name in the search box
select it and click done
now that we've saved our change our
inspection template details page
specifies three
info types note this template path at
the top of the page
we'll use that in a second to see our
template in action
let's check out this inspection request
instead of constructing an inspection
configuration object
for this inspection request we can
simply reference the inspection template
we created using the path name
like this our response of course will be
the results of the inspection
as expected we've got a phone number an
email and a name this is
really useful if you have several
inspection jobs set up against different
data sources that inspect for the same
info types
instead of editing each inspection
configuration separately you can simply
update the template details hold up a
second
what about the identification well the
second type of dlp template is a
de-identification template
a de-identification template is going to
save any configuration having to do the
process
of de-identifying your data for every
positive result
in a de-identification request the
template will have a corresponding
transformation to apply to it this is
also where you would specify
transformation specific customizations
like replacement strings or encryption
keys
the identification templates can be
applied not only to inspection results
but also to values in the specified
field in a database table
[Music]
here's an example of how we can use the
create de-identify template function to
create
a new de-identification template
here we're specifying that we want to
replace email addresses with the
corresponding info type
and we also want to make sure that the
names are replaced with custom
replacement value
once it's been created here's what the
template looks like back in our cloud
console
each info type we specified and its
transformation is listed here
as a transformation rule just like our
inspect template
we can edit it here to include
additional info types
let's edit this template to apply
masking to phone numbers
down here we'll add a transformation
rule
and choose mask with character now we
can configure our masking for this
transformation rule
we'll specify the info type phone number
down here where it says
manage info types now that it's saved
there's our new transformation rule
the identification templates include a
test page where we can get a quick
preview of the transformations we
configured in the template
emails will be replaced with info type
names are going to be replaced with a
replacement string
and phone numbers will be masked with
hash symbols
now let's see our de-identification
template do its thing in a
de-identification request
instead of including a de-identify
config block in our request
we can reference our de-identification
template once again using the path name
from the details page
you'll notice that we're referencing our
inspection template from before to
specify what info types we're inspecting
for
and here is a response from the request
the inspection template found a phone
number name and email address
and a data notification template applied
the transformations we specified
accordingly using templates is a
powerful way to decouple your inspection
and de-identification configuration from
your workflows
and your implementation inspection
templates can be configured to inspect
up to 150 built-in and custom info types
and the identification templates can use
any combination of the identification
techniques to de-identify
the results we use a really simple
example
but the value of templates really shines
for kitty cat walks when they got their
data that needs to be inspected and
de-identified
coming from their web and mobile apps
archived on gcs buckets
and stored on a number of databases
reviewing templates was a great way to
kind of bring everything together
next time we'll wrap things up with an
extended episode where we'll dive into
configuring dlp in the google cloud
console
see you soon
[Music]
you